I want to make a toast to chase on his
big VMA performance no matter what
Burger King said where is chase oh he's
over there talking to Michael che the
grind never stops but chase isn't the
only one I'm proud of
to my Care Bear who's gonna be in a big
fancy Hollywood movie with chase called
Debra is missing no bad it's not called
Debra's missing a stars Debra Messing
but thank you and brookie Little Miss
manager to think that six months ago I
would cry myself to sleep so worried
about you
but look at you now thanks mom always
great at toes Pat why don't you tell
them you're a big career news oh no no
it's nothing tonight is about my kids
oh wait where's Lance I wanted to toast
his shoes oh um he couldn't make it
oh that's too bad is everything okay
what oh yeah yeah I'm fine
hey can I get a card for the table oh
you can just put it under Billy Eichner
of course
actually no I'm a proud single a
businesswoman you can put it under
Brooke due back of course actually no
guys it's really busy tonight I love
this family and I hope to always be a
part of it so take this and put it on my
card
of course mr. Peters wait your name is
Streeter Peters yes
hey guys
hey buddy what's going on I'm glad
you're all here because I've been
thinking and I have a big announcement
all this singing stuff has been really
cool but this fall I'm gonna go to
college
what college
[Music]
[Applause]
I am oh god I'm so sorry I I thought he
said he was gonna go to conference I did
I was talking to Michael che about
what's next for my career and he said
maybe I should go to college so I think
I'm gonna go okay so you're just not
gonna be a singer anymore
I guess not because I'd be in college
yeah well I think that's great honey
yeah yeah so do i I think it's great I
think it's great but um you know I
here's an idea how about we sleep on it
if you still want to go tomorrow we can
apply that oh I don't need to apply
already got into NYU mmm what Oh Carrie
like you almost yeah I tweeted at them
and they said I could come oh well what
about all the cool stuff yep coming up
you streeter
he got you a movie I don't want to do a
movie I want to go to college yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no no yah yah yah
yah yah yah yah yah yah Wayne yeah yeah
it's great you know it's so good so
great I'm gonna go thank mikaël myself
excuse me hi mr. Chae hey did you just
um tell my brother chase that he should
go to college yeah I thought that'd
probably be the best thing for me dude
yeah well as his sister I just wanted to
say I agree because I think education is
important well it's great but as his
manager I just I want to say you're a
real piece of whoa
well that comes from why why because I
have finally figured out what it is that
I want to do with my life and what I'm
good at and you come along and you've
made I mean not like that
I mean unless no definitely not it's
just of course I want him to go to
college if that's what he wants to do
but but what about me like what am I
supposed to do I mean you can go to
college too Jesus what do you work for
college all right listen Michael che you
seem like a good guy
I mean I'm fine but you took something
from me tonight and you took something
from my brother Kerry so I'm gonna take
something from you yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna take your drinks I'm taking these
they're mine now yeah
thinking of killing yourself
what no if it wasn't for the hot new
lady in my life I'd be dead in the
bathroom already you know hot lady she
doesn't want me to tell anybody yet but
let's just say she's a very special
woman you don't know I'm sure I doubt
straighter beautiful
she raised three beautiful children
again you don't know okay straighter I
hope that someday me and this beautiful
woman who you do not know can take it to
the next level please don't talk about
you two having sex I can't give out
marriage I'm thinking about marriage we
already had sex
[Music]
you wanna get out of here yes
you